hey guys help me going so today I'm
really excited because I'm joined with
Jenna and I'm joined with what is in
this box which is the new gold MacBook
are you ready to help me unbox this I
think I am alright shall we I think we
should whoa
I'm a little nervous because I don't
want to be disappointed
just open it okay it is so tiny
holy moly let's do a size comparison
thin nice I'm gonna get a knife I didn't
I okay oh I found a fork goes first
thing I found okay no no where to so all
I know is my current MacBook Pro is
double the specs of this one so I am not
expecting much and I know that this is
not going to be a machine that I'm gonna
be doing hi processor intensive editing
I'm not gonna be rendering out any 4k
films anytime soon you can write some
emails I can write some emails I can
probably do some simple editing I'm
gonna be excited to actually test it out
to see what I can do with this little
guy you can take it to the coffee shop
and look fabulous take it to the coffee
shop salvage touch my macbook pro oh I
don't think that's how 50 cent intended
that song to go anyway
pity no open I'm really I'm actually
excited because here's the thing I know
is a sense she's feeling yeah so maybe a
lot of people were skeptical but anytime
I've been skeptical of Apple they've
always kind of impressed I opened the
book whoa
it's like rose gold if beautiful I
thought it was gonna be like a glug Lego
like pea gold like when you're
dehydrated pea stock you can see oh my
god that it's everyone's been dehydrated
before I'm a little impressed with it
it's definitely it looks rose gold I
want to smell it doesn't smell good oh
wow so kind actually looks on screen to
be a little more gold but in person this
thing looks rose head shine a little
light on you that's not the words Oh
Shawn shimmering splendid Oh Matt books
and look at it look at it do you me to
do a close-up gee I can't move no I'm
just kind of trying to get in light ah
it looks really good I thought it was
gonna suck no respect
oh I know wait oh there's a new charger
huh yeah of course there's a new charger
so the new charger is actually USB see
there are no ports currently on this
macbook other than USB C port so USB C
is kind of changing the game because
you're going to be able to use this for
you're gonna be able to use this port
for basically everything transferring
files and most importantly charging this
is now how you will charge your MacBook
all right let's boot this up
blew it up okay I'm not sure so here it
is this isn't very long it doesn't look
very long really short it should be much
short let's do our met our form of
measuring so I am 5 5 5 5 3 it's about 6
foot it's about it's about 6 foot its me
if I had a really high hat on high hat
Wow Wow did you see that can we get a
slow-mo it looks the same good it does
look good to use English for the me
excuse me
alright you things were happen she blows
everybody she was okay we do you want to
hold up hearing your rate yawn yeah so
the new keyboard was redesigned and they
have this thing called the butterfly
mechanism and I can't wait to actually
type on it don't transfer any of my
information we're just trying to don't
find me and honey we just need to see
what we got no way honey and skip I have
to see it in a different light can you
bring them with us of course alright
guys welcome to my apartment here we're
going into the kitchen the white balance
is off so just take my word for it
cancel the kitchen setup I am a typing
machine I am typing oops Bubba something
wrong
it looks really good looks
holy-moly Justine is making me type a
lot of a lot go
so as MacBook comes in three different
colors there's the silver the gold and
the Space Gray you can also choose from
two different models this one is the 1.1
gigahertz model which has 256 gigs of
hard drive space which actually isn't
that much you can choose to upgrade
which will only give you a 1.2 gigahertz
boost and a hard drive of 512 megs which
still not really that much if you're
getting this computer this isn't
something that you're gonna be doing
crazy editing or anything to processor
intensive alright guys thanks so much
for watching let me know what you guys
think of the new MacBook let me know
what you guys think of the new Apple
watch that should be out very very
shortly and I'm so excited I love Apple
I love technology I freaking love the
internet I love you guys thanks oh I
love you too doesn't say it's my sister
she knows she 9 I don't I don't need it
I'll see you guys later thanks for
watching bye